salut c'est enfin la suite et fin de
cette première expérience mentale qui a
été un succès merci à tous d'avoir
participé merci à tous ceux qui m'ont
aidé on y reviendra
je suis même déjà en train de préparer
la suivante je vous rappelle rapidement
les faits à la base c'était une
espérance de 1942 que j'ai reprise où le
but est de voir s'il ya une différence
significative entre ceux qui croient au
pouvoir si psi et non ps y sommes il y
en a qu'il le pensait mais c'est pas ça
donc s'il ya une différence entre ces
deux catégories les moutons et les
chèvres sur leur perception extra
sensorielle
ça a été très difficile d'avoir
exactement le protocole de l'époque donc
j'ai mis le mien en place pour pour
cette version moderne de 2007 qu'est ce
qu'il en est ressorti génériques
trente mille participants vous a été
trente mille à répondre en fait vous
avez été plus de 30000 à répondre mais
je n'ai pris aucune des réponses qu'ils
n'avaient pas renseigner son adresse
mail puisque le but en mettant l'adresse
mail qui était pas le but parfait non
plus parce que chacun peut en créer une
c'était que chaque personne ne participe
qu'une seule fois quatre personnes m'ont
également aider à traiter les données
des gens qui sont bien plus calés que
moi en maths soit à faire leurs propres
calculs soit vérifié les miens merci à
eux quatre je le voulais site à la fin
le protocole de l'expérience que j'ai
mis en place il est bien où il est pas
bien peu importe il est ce qu'il est
c'est ça qui est important à prendre en
compte dire que quand on va interpréter
les données il faut garder en compte
quel a été mon protocole mon protocole
était le sud ont fait le test en vidéo
donc on n'est pas en temps réel ensemble
l'un à côté de l'autre
deuxièmement pour faire un rappel des
symboles de nerfs je les ai laissés à
côté dans l'ordre classique le cercle
lacroix les vagues le carré et l'étoile
c'était ce petit papier ça peut
influencer les résultats ça peut
influencer sur la manière de répondre en
tout cas c'est un fait
il était là pour tout le monde à
l'époque aussi on leur a forcément
rappeler quels étaient les symboles
moi j'avais pris le parti de le mettre
dans l'ordre classique elle de laisser
sur la vidéo encore une fois c'est
quelque chose à prendre en compte dans
mon protocole dans la manière dont je
les fais c'est pas bien ou pas bien
c'est comme ça il ça existe en tout cas
troisièmement personne ne connaissait
l'ordre des symboles sous les bristols
même pas moi puisque j'avais tout
mélanger donc personne personne n'était
au courant donc si jamais je pouvais
envoyer des choses avec des ondes
cérébrales ou je ne sais quoi
impossible de le savoir quatrième chose
toutes les personnes ne font donc qu'un
seul et c'est peut-être qu'en 1942 les
personnes faisait plusieurs essais etc
ont noté les résultats cinquièmement et
ça c'est pas une différence des moindres
les personnes savent à quoi ils et elles
partent ici je suis pas certain que
c'était le cas à l'époque et enfin 6e
chose je saurai parce que j'ai beaucoup
de trop de mal à dire cette phrase il ya
eu plein de coupe la future donc 6e
chose donc 6 g [ __ ] donc 6e chose à
savoir est à prendre en compte c'est que
ce sont les personnes même les
participants eux mêmes qui ont jaugés de
leur degré de croyance au nom dans les
pouvoirs qs c'est pas un questionnaire
sur lequel nous on a décidé qu'en
fonction des réponses à ce questionnaire
c'était des gens qui croyaient au patois
si c'était une demande directe voilà
c'est un rappel c'est important de
savoir ça quand vous faites une collecte
de données il faut aussi savoir quel
était le protocole exact c'est pas grave
qui ait des choses bien ou pas bien du
monde qu'on connaît tous le protocole
comment il s'est déroulé maintenant je
vous fait de l'ouverture des symboles
derrière le premier bristol se cacher le
cercle derrière le deuxième se cacher
les vagues derrière le troisième se
cacher le car est derrière le quatrième
se cacher lacroix est forcément derrière
le cinquième
on avait les toiles tout d'abord
l'univers des possibles et 220
possibilité donc la probabilité que tout
soit juste en essayant de capter dans
quel ordre sur les symboles et d'une
chance sur cent vingt le nombre moyen d'
erreurs commises et de 3,125 c'est comme
ça c'est mathématique on a eu la chance
encore une fois d'avoir quelqu'un qui
nous a détaillé tout calcul pour prouver
sa mathématiquement que le nom moyens
d'erreur est de 325 on va dire la ligne
du hasard je vous mets ce fichier là
dans la description niveau des croyants
c'est à dire des groupes
j'avais rajouté un troisième groupe qui
est elle est neutre il ya eu 7825
croyant au poids psy 4287 non croyants
et 14 1389 neutre quand on a fait les
calculs et les comparaisons les
différences significatives ou non qu'il
ya entre les groupes on a essayé sur
toute la totalité sur la masse est aussi
en rationalisant en faisant une moyenne
par groupes ou en essayant par exemple
de prendre 4287 croyant au hasard pour
les comparer à queen 287 non croyants il
s'est avéré que ça nous donne à chaque
fois les mêmes résultats
la finalité c'est que les résultats sont
plutôt homogène entre les trois groupes
on a à peu près les mêmes
résultat le même donc d'erreurs au
global le même au nombre de personnes
qui ont fait que deux erreurs que trois
erreurs que quatre erreurs ou tout juste
le fait d'appartenir à tel ou tel groupe
n'a eu aucune incidence de différence
entre ses crocs on est sur un nombre
moyen d'erreur de 3,9 sur la totalité
des participants donc un peu plus erreur
d'ailleurs que la ligne du hasard mais
dans l'expérience de 47 c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que les personnes qui
croyaient aux pouvoirs psy était à peu
près sur la même ligne que la ligne
d'erreur probable alors que ceux qui ne
croyaient pas au foie psy faisait
beaucoup plus d'erreurs que la ligne
d'erreur globale et c'est ça qui était
intéressant c'est ça qui était
significatif
ça se retrouve pas du tout dans
l'expérience qu'on vient de refaire nous
ensemble
mathématiquement on peut dire qu'il ya
une différence quand même statistique
significative mais significative dans le
sens où elles existent parce qu'en fait
aller quasiment négligeable la
différence statistique moyenne et 2 p
égal 0,04 cent cinquante air entre le
groupe croyant le groupe non croyants le
seul petit chose amusante c'est que
croyants non croyants est neutre et fait
plus d'erreurs que le hasard peut être
que vous vous avez envie d'extirper
d'autres choses de ces résultats c'est
tout à fait possible je vous mets tous
les résultats également en espèces
d'open source dans la description vous
pouvez les télécharger et vous en faites
ce que vous voulez vous pouvez les
triturer comme vous voulez je vous mets
également toujours dans la description
un fichier graphique simplifiée que m'a
fourni l'une des personnes qui m'a aidé
en fait à traiter les résultats qui
s'appelle d'orient où vous pourrez voir
dessus directement les pourcentages sur
zéro erreur deux erreurs 3 4 et 5 sur
26500 une réponse traité sachez quand
même qu'il ya eu 240 personnes qui ont
eu tout juste voilà ça sert à rien me
jouer le dire ça fait moins de 1 % des
participants est proportionnellement le
groupe qui a eu le plus de personnes qui
ont trouvé les 5 bonnes réponses
c'est le groupe des neutres 0 94% des
neutres versus 0,85 à 0 86% des groupes
croyants et non-croyants bon d'une
manière ou d'une autre l'espérance de
1942 doit être biaisé quelque part il
doit y avoir un élément qui n'en ont pas
ou quelque chose qui doit expliquer
c'est assez dur d'avoir toutes les infos
précises sur ce sujet là je peux pas
vous dire néanmoins j'aimerais remercier
vivement quatre personnes et ne quittez
pas la vidéo parce qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes à savoir sur eux
j'aimerais remercier nicolas brion qui
actuellement à shanghai
pour son dernier stage de fin d'études
en école d'ingénieur et qui a checké
tous ces résultats
merci à dorian caudal qui est de nantes
c'est un docteur en neurosciences qu'on
connaît bien d'un milieu et de la magie
et également du mentalisme parce qu'il a
écrit un livre sur le mirent à cannes le
n ecard at any number un peu comme ce
qu'avait fait top 10 lui il en a une
version qui est logique rationnelle
il a écrit un livre là-dessus je vous
mets liens dans la description merci à
ruben de pareils qui travaillent en bio
statistique également et enfin à jérémy
que les trois autres ne connaissent pas
qui m'a contacté indépendamment et je
lui ai envoyé aussi toutes les données
de manière indépendante pour pas qu'ils
voient le travail qu'on faisait pour
essayer de voir tout ça voyez l'idée
c'était de passes plantes et donc au
final croyants non croyants neutre pas
neutre les marges d'erreur était à peu
près équivalente
on a tous fait un peu plus pire que le
hasard en moyenne y'a pas grand chose à
en retirer si ce n'est que du coup
l'effet mouton chèvre qui est un exemple
comprend souvent que même moi j'avais
pris dans une vidéo ce qui m'avait donné
envie de faire celle ci mais peut-être
pas s'ils valident ou valable que ça
j'espère que tout ce concept-là vous
aura plu genre relancerait un autre le
mois prochain sur notre expérience est
un autre sujet un autre truc qu'on
pourra faire ensemble et voir ce qui se
passe
encore une fois je vous le rappelle tout
est dans la description si vous même
vous voulez essayer d'en ressortir
quelque chose d'intéressant
n'hésitez pas à me l'envoyer dans ce cas
là dites moi dans les commentaires le
nombre d'erreurs que vous vous aviez
fait qu'on essaie de trouver des
personnes qui avaient tout faux une
personne qui avait tout juste et comme
d'habitude si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce en
l'air et à vous abonner rendez vous très
bientôt avant la fin de la semaine
ciao
[Musique]